okay we are
live I don't know why all this garbage
is on my
desktop put this over
there
so we got a lot of stuff to do
today check a few
things I uh I managed to get the GPU
environment running with some caveats
late last night
and it's pretty nice but we have a lot a
lot of work to do
today we're on a little earlier than
normal there's linky
welcome right on
and Let's
do let's just keep it like this today
and there's a thing that I had to do I
to set a library path in order to make
this work it was really obnoxious but I
got it
working this F this export right here I
don't know why this path was wrong but
the path was wrong
uh right so I tried to run a sweep
yesterday a hyper parameter sweep that
didn't end up
working but if I'm in the right machine
here uh which I think I am
then what we should see is we should see
some build stuff which I really wish
that this would be
cached we'll have to figure that
out but it will compile some stuff and
then it should
run in GPU
mode and there you have
it 37 is thousand oscillates back and
forth this can be massively increased
which this is going to be the aim today
um we also have some containerization
stuff to
do that's really boring though and uh I
want to start with something more
interesting so let me just make sure I
don't have
any outstanding messages or anything
from the uh the NYU folks
old hold on let me grab uh the slack for
this make sure I didn't miss any
messages and then we have something
really cool to Dev
today something very cool
I like how slack asks you like four
separate times are you sure you don't
want to use our shitty electron
app oh cool um so I have a
reply from the author of
Madrona C CPU they say the CPU backend
is already internally vectorized I
know it's why I'm spawning one thread
per
not
okay we updated the red notifications
nothing changed
default argument to the config
the defaults to
zero I think I have a Twitter DM from
this guy actually as well let me check
on
that starts num core CPU threads
is this the default is this what I was
messing with at the
529 oh it's in GPU drive itself that's
why it wasn't working before
this
um
config threadpool executor config so I
just have to do
dot num workers equal
one and midun will pin the thread to
core zero which is not what you want
close let me go get uh let me go get
Twitter because I think I have a DM on
this let me grab
that make sure this is nothing
private oh no this is somebody
else never mind
else I forgot to rep to them last night
but I did post on this
cool I think I found everything for now
I think I found everything for
today
oops let me find the piece of code that
I was
linked um there was a cool discussion on
this they linked me like very similar
stuff
threads yeah okay here's the
code so they actually told me that this
was based off of puffer Leb which was
kind of cool to
OBS sometimes I wish my adviser would
just let me to contribute to puffer L as
my
focus there's some good stuff in
puffer there's some good stuff in puffer
for sure
you can just you can use puffer and PR
anything that you find that needs fixing
or any improvements you make along the
way
H okay this is not
exactly not exactly what I
ah language models have taken over
everything I
assume shame
they were pretty
close they were pretty
close so
um yeah I know I know how we're going to
do this
it's going to take a fair bit of work
though
so the plan for today let me get outline
at a high level cuz I think do we have
some folks on YouTube right oh shoot
already eight that's
crazy um so here's the plan for today
and let me get all this stuff out of the
way so it's not covering chat
um last night I got this working on GPU
later today once I get a little more
tired and I don't have you know the
energy to do the higher intensity work
I'll rebuild all the containers maybe
towards the evening and I will ship this
up so everybody can use
it it's not
sus they're friends of mine and they
they site puffer lib in their manuscript
as
well so
the thing is
like people are going to do this until
they realize that it's actually
incredibly incredibly easy to work with
puffer and me because I literally sit
here and do this all day so like if you
make a binding for puffer and need help
you're not going to be waiting around
for a week for replies I'll just like be
like oh yeah sure let me do that right
now live right it's going to take a
while for people to realize that yes
it's actually that easy to like add
stuff um to get me to add stuff
but anyways here's the plan for today
right now what you do is you specify a
maximum number of Agents per environment
like 32 or something like that right and
then it gives you back a big clunky
tensor that has all that data in it um
but it's padded so then you have to take
all that garbage data that like most is
padding send it through the Ford pass of
the neural
network
and keep going until you collect enough
real data that's not padding in order to
fill up your experience buffer does that
make sense and it's like 90% padding 90%
inefficiency so what we're going to
do is we're going to take the data from
the environment undo all that padding
nonsense and from there uh we are going
to have just like the tensor be the size
of the number of agents and that should
make stuff way
faster and it's let us run more parallel
environments as
well now it's interesting that they told
me that the Sim internally doesn't
need doesn't actually need to
[Music]
return technically what I'm about to do
would be faster if it were in the C++
but that actually will take them time to
change so I'm just going to do it from
here it shouldn't take that long
how did you learn to create GPU
drivers I do not know how to make GPU
drivers this is GPU driving Sim not GPU
drivers this is not my GPU driving Sim
either this is NYU Sim I also write high
performance Sims that are equally as
fast I write like million step per
second uh Sims but minor
CPU they're written in syon and run in
pure
C and I did not learn it in University
University classes teach you actually
nothing like literally you get a CS
degree you show up for work you do not
know how to do a damn thing the only
thing you know how to do is teach
yourself how to do other things and like
probably understand basics of algorithm
complexity and system design so that
you'll be looking in the right direction
like your degree entitles you to another
decade's worth of learning stuff and
much more thereafter
takes a
while I have lots of things that I think
that like could potentially save people
a ton of time along the way but like if
I were to give myself this myself from
10 years ago this advice I know I
wouldn't
listen so I don't know how useful it
um
uhhuh mhm
hm okay this is not
bad not
bad um I do have to do a couple things
that are kind of awkward
here
so the first thing I need to do
is this reset function
here has to go
reset and then what we need to do is we
need to make a
function that's like unpad
and then what we're going to
do
is set a break point because I have to
do this interactively this is
hard
um a few things in the meantime we have
the controlled agent mask
right I think I probably still just have
to do this interactively this is going
to be
hard for
oh this is actually not bad we have the
exact mask we need don't
self it's a bull yeah it is so do OBS of
self. controlled to agent mask
that's
nice
reasonable I think it's that simple
actually I think I was just being
dumb
yeah I think that's literally
it that's actually kind of
not going to need this
anymore uh reset does
OBS now what we do
is I see so we just have to move some
stuff it takes me a second of kind of
quietly thinking before I can
properly um explain what I'm doing here
but so what all I have to do is there's
this numb agents
thing yeah right here that's currently
set to the padded value what I have to
do is I have to reset the m so that I
can
get uh this shape here and it's just
going to be self. OBS do
shape okay and then this is now going to
be s.n num
agents and now I actually have
appropriate size buffers
right we're not going to use that
function but I'll leave it there for
now episode returns is now going to be a
flat
buffer I think
I might need like agents per M or
something
right
yeah we'll think about that in a
second but for now at
least controlled agent
mask is a CPU
tensor I don't actually don't want it to
be a CPU tensor I want this to be a GPU
tensor
and then this will
be
clone
p okay so OBS is
s.m. getet OBS of self. controlled agent
mask
rewards self duck controlled agent
mask self talk controlled agent mask we
can actually
do like
tricky we're going this is the portion
that'll be
hard let me see if there's anything else
that's going to be
hard does not look like it so [ __ ]
I think I need to do this
slightly slightly
I think I was pretty
close I think I just need to set this
terminal a little different
terminal yeah this tells you what's
done and then you're allowed to do
CPU I don't like that I'm moving this
multiple times
[Music]
H was fine for now
though no longer need these two
lines because
um we no longer need those two lines
because um we are now have flat data
and it's so tricky to figure out how to
make these things like this it's
conceptually not that complicated but
it's very easy to make errors and very
hard to catch them so I tend to just go
very slow and move very carefully with
this type of
stuff
infos done worlds okay
I might want to run this on CPU a little
bit we
fine got to love bugs that look like
that it just takes an obnoxious amount
of time to get used to finding them and
recognizing them
easy just have to define the mvids
according to the agent IDs instead of
according to padded agent
IDs uh
value we're still getting bad values
I suspect because
um we have size mismatches
somehow let me
interesting welcome YouTube folks who
like watching me debug random simulation
code
um all this stuff will be publicly
available as soon as I get around to
committing it and it will be on the
puffer tank container as well so it will
be very very easy to play around with I
think it's like a 12 13 gigabyte
container last I checked but um you know
once you download it it's very easy to
use from
there I spent a little extra time last
night to figure out how to get this to
run on GPU though I don't know if it'll
be faster on GPU we're also we also have
the potential to make single thread CPU
work today and if we can do single
thread CPU then I can use my own
multiprocessing implementation which
should be faster than their
multi-threading I
also kind of want to do that because the
creator of Madrona messaged me that like
hey you know anything you're going to do
on python with the vectorization is just
going to be fundamentally slower than
the C++
multi-threading which I know that's not
true it kind of makes me want to show
that it
Gil see the funny thing is
that my stuff is not limited by the Gil
because it's like essentially zero
zero overhead python
multiprocessing because of the I found
some tricks with shared
memory I think they're like a few it's
like I think it's either High singled
digigit or low double digigit microsc
overhead on the main thread that I
couldn't get
around that's it though
which is really funny because it's like
what the heck do you mean performance
Engineering in Python yeah I mean
performance Engineering in
Python wouldn't it be faster in C++ well
no because it has to work with python
objects you'd have to copy all the
objects a
here compiling out the
Gil n
man it's not a problem we're we're fast
okay we're fast
okay that actually tells me what I
needed to
know that this is failing on reset
somehow so I'm assuming that these are
just not the shapes that I think that
they
are oh did I do mask wrong yeah I did
Mask wrong my bad
ons thoughts on
noil I actually don't know if it's going
to help puffer or not it looks
interesting
um I actually don't know enough about
how Hardware interacts with threading to
be able to answer
that because you're you're technically
like supposed to have two Hardware
threads I don't know if you do you
actually ever get speedups like on pure
compute bound workloads do you ever get
speedups equal to number of Hardware
threads instead of Hardware
cores CU it's like two Hardware threads
per core or
whatever I don't know if you ever get
that the multi-processing we have is
very very optimized so I don't know if
we get any additional benefit by going
to threads it probably make some stuff
simpler but then again like I don't
trust the python threading Primitives to
be fast enough for what we want so like
even like the communication like the
threading communication which should be
instantaneous cuz it's in the same
memory space like if those functions
have 10 microc overhead my
multiprocessing is going to be
faster I mean to give you an idea I
didn't use pipes send and receive from
pipes because there was 40 micros
overhead and that was too much so I got
rid of pipes to save 40 microc and that
was a huge
Improvement I like performance
engineering multiple
threads the thread scale I don't
actually know this do threads scale
above the number of cores in your C uh
in do do threads get you performance
above the number of cores on your
machine because there are technically
like two Hardware cores Hardware threads
or whatever I don't understand the
hardware side that much I know that
processors typically they're they have
two Hardware threads per core or
whatever but I don't actually know what
that means in terms of the optimization
is that truly two things running at the
same time or is that just like optimized
like caching like switching or whatever
asking it's whether there's Hardware it
has nothing to do with
python the thread scale above Hardware
CPUs I don't know
there might be a factor of two and there
might
now we want to do indexing on the CPU
not the GPU right
because puffer is going to return
numpy at least until we
optimize I guess we'll optimize in a bit
so it won't matter
right so yeah for now what we'll do is
this is on GPU
to self
device then we'll do self.
actions was
action we do self
dot.
action okay so what this is doing is
it's taking our
actions they're flat
data and it's putting them back in the
original padded data that the C++
environment
stupid everybody keeps talking about
this bug like this error message but
it's you get used to it pretty
welcome currently we are working
on accelerating this learning process by
making it not not return 90%
padding that is the current state of
affairs and it
is a little
tricky not too bad I'm hoping we get
good per out of this today they told me
that they get uh this is this Linker uh
they told me that they get 50,000 steps
per second performance which if their
Sim actually gets to be a million then
that's quite bad if they if we can get a
million out of the Sim then I can get
several hundred, out of the neural
yeah we're going to have some cool Tech
out
today okay so the issue is that this
need need to be like this this is the
one place we actually
need the actions buffer has to be
padded and then it's
the uh this buffer that's not padded
Vim no the absolute madman was me using
no plugins standard Vim for like seven
years from like high school through I
don't know up to like two three years
ago
this is at least NE them with a whole
entire two
cool I probably should be running this
in the other window so I don't have to
be tabbing all the time right
mask did I get rid of this
thing yes yes I do
this I'm surprised you
don't t-u with VI and open in a
pain um I used to have
I3 t-m is too much bloat for me to be
honest the only thing I use t-x for is
keeping experiments alive
did you see tweet about rhf on not being
yeah well everybody knows that that like
rhf is baby mode RL right like it's a
totally different use case of it it
really doesn't leverage many of the
advantages whatsoever of reinforcement
learning and I don't think I don't know
agree that it's Alpha go type systems
either I don't think you need explicit
search for RL to be
useful I think like learning from
scratch without search is fine as long
as you have stupidly fast
simulators which is what we're building
here building stupidly fast
simulators and every so often you know
helping out with other
peoples to be fair a lot of my
conviction on RL it it depends on this
one Schulman paper being
correct so I don't know if anybody wants
to go see if they can find any errors in
the single agent scaling laws for RL
paper let me know but it matches my own
intuition and I think it's probably
good so
[Music]
this might be
it I keep forgetting I have this other
tab here
only thing with applying RL to LMS is
how you find a reward
system
H not really it's like the thing is RL
is really good at just sucking up
unlimited quantities of data whereas
language models are really bad at that
because they're big and clunky they have
lots of parameters and need lots of
compute like language models are trained
on a pathetic amount of data when you
think about it like there's basically no
data used for training
whatsoever like oh no we use a whole 10
terabytes of data it's like cool my I do
that on one GPU in a day with
do oh yeah this is a little obnoxious
isn't it
maybe something like yes it would I
really miss
I3 it's massive time sync yep there is
technically one for Windows as well I'm
just too lazy because it breaks stuff it
was kind of made just for me as well
like it's the exact thing I would want
to use I just am too lazy because it's
not part of the
OS I don't know I could download it it's
pretty
cool it's like the exact thing I would
want it doesn't have
um oh did they add this yeah they added
the they added a split
okay
cool I like this
thing I played with it for a
bit I know we'll see next time I want to
SC around with something I don't mess
with my tools too that too
much but yes I had
uh the undergrad years for me were like
Ultra tryhard Arch plus I3 on custom
built water cool desktop that I you know
hack together
thing would be great to see yet another
coma with the Omniverse
M let me see this
this
Nvidia oh
this there's no way these are fast right
wait is this what you
mean there's no way this thing is
fast right
oh Isaac wait
this oh yeah this thing
okay yeah this is this is potentially
more
see configuring Linux is a huge time
sync
it's the thing is it's it's the type of
thing that's good to do when you're new
to computer and you want to learn stuff
quickly but it rapidly becomes a waste
of time
after fast as GPU
goes yeah if it's the one it's the Isaac
Sim one then yeah I actually there are
some people that I that I have uh that
might be interested in doing that
running headless is good well mandatory
really hold on let me think about how I
want to do a thing with
make the live agent mask like this and
then we'll do this
here does this
work I think it
does oops so used to tapping this
I really like the puffer stack that I
have here
because it's just it's a Docker
container that I can pull from
anywhere and then it I just have my
neovim defaults in here so that's my
whole editor and everything so I
basically can just use this container
from anywhere and I'll always have the
same consistent Dev
environment oh [ __ ] we actually have
this thing running don't we and way
faster
though we don't update self. mask
anywhere do we
yeah because this has to be changed hold
on data
density yeah yeah that's not going to be
that fast there's no
way I fought Docker for a long time but
it's Docker is the
way like yeah people say oh I just have
good cond I could have VMS it doesn't
matter they take too long to spin up
Docker spins up
instantly any books resources you'd
recommend start doing stuff right like
you it's you read papers maybe there's
like the open ey spinning up stuff but
then like you've graduated
congratulations you start you start
actually working on stuff
right like I didn't read a bunch of
books to start doing RL like I read a
decent chunk of papers and I wrote a lot
of
code and it is much much easier nowadays
to just start writing some RL code than
it used to be believe
me much
easier back in my day we had to work off
of Open ai's absolute garbage baselines
repository in order to do anything that
was fun
let me tell
live well we've been thinking
about uh M's were always a weak point in
RL yeah not anymore though
not
anymore okay so now the really cool
thing about this data density
be finding problems to try and build
there have been lots of people in here
that have been just like picking up
puffer and jamming some Ultra fast
environments if you have like some
software e background at least um um
Noah's been doing this awesome fast
breakout thing there's somebody else in
here I'll know him when I see him
there's another guy it might have been
Nathan who was uh starting on
Tetris use like just make million step
per second M to contribute to puffer
right
okay so 17K right now but this is with
CPU
Pablo I present to
you the puffer
cluster this is literally what we run
stuff on this is it
oh oops it's Cuda not
jpu they support a lot of different
devices that's kind of nutty
would so we're not getting
um we're just not getting the perf out
of the environment right
maybe
so you might
say Joseph you say that you don't ever
use code complete for stuff why are you
why are you possibly code completing all
of this stuff and it's going to write a
whole bunch of
garbage well viewer it's code completing
with my own
code this is my code it stole this from
another file on the same
project it didn't even do do that
perfectly wow
buffer cluster is near top tier
that's
cluster I told you I want to build that
thing out way more though we might do it
with AMD after the whole Intel
debacle
um we'll see once I start getting
revenue for the company we'll see how
long it takes once I launch uh to start
getting some clients but but one of the
relatively early goals for puffer is
going to be to go from a $30,000 cluster
to a
$250,000
cluster that will give us a lot of
that'll give us like a pretty decent
chunk of compute to use that'll like we
can sponsor a ton of cool open source
work with that as well
can imagine the sweeps yeah that'll be
nice we got to get there though which
means people have to follow the Twitter
and people have to Star Puffer in order
for that to happen star the puffer
that's really
dumb uh
huh maybe I shouldn't have Nam my model
files torch. pie
cluster Computing with fiber uplinks
yeah but that gets expensive then you go
from being able to buy 50 machines with
250k to being able to buy like two
machines basically would all have to be
custom outside of the boxes is why the
desktops are so
upgrade oh
you just want fiber upload speed is that
all you
want we're not wiring the boxes together
that's when you get Nvidia mad at
you we will absolutely have better
transfer speeds
this is so
obnoxious can I just like
it GPU Drive
what I don't have a
torch import
what import
torch
oh not doing it
it I don't want to do I don't want to
have to go rename all the model files I
yeah they shouldn't have been named
torch. P to begin with but
just like all these garbage begin our
python blogs
I'm going to just rename it for now and
then
I'll I'll uh because I'm not going to
just waste time doing
this no module named Pi GPU Drive oh
jeez this can't even be run from
yeah it needs to be run from
okay it's really
oh because it's going to do the
underscore
I should have done I should have just
done this a while ago this is silly to
be stuck on for any amount of time
cannot
import really
because this is just me being half
asleep okay
um
there now this works
cuz I didn't reset
it should have been reset up here
no
uh no
perf only
41k so something is definitely wrong
because I'm not getting the it's the
environment itself that's slow let me do
a c proof test
test
performance
n
this so maybe we can figure out where
we're losing all our
perf make sure it's actually not in the
rapper before I tell them like hey not
getting the perf
no it's all on step Dynamics pretty much
there's a little bit of wrapper
overhead let me kill all the python
processes to make sure
we'll see what uh what we get out of
this
oops hey just jumped on the stream
welcome that's actually perfect timing
um I did the thing that we talked about
I have dense data coming out of your
environment now not from the C++ but at
least from the python side uh so
perfectly dense uh except being for
agents that die but this which ends up
being a lot of them um but I'm still
having issues with the the perf of this
uh unless this test comes back faster
I'm only getting like 40,000 or so steps
per second out of the GPU environment
itself so I don't know if I'm doing
something wrong probably I have some
config
settings export thank you that is what
I've wanted
that's very nice let me actually add
that before I forget
okay remember to delete the cache
file ah I
see and do slgp okay I
see that's
cool
ah stupid
cool so now I'll make sure I add that
in wrapper is slower than the raw
Sim the pytorch
wrapper or what
rapper 42k is not like we can't do
anything with this right we need to
get can the Sim return
gym what gym
wrapper okay the other thing I was
confused about is this is not a gym
environment in the first place like JY
is a single agent API and it returns
numpy arrays so I'll show you what I'm
using
uh Pi J what is it Pi GPU drive and
torch I'm using M torch
the only thing I've added is I've added
some like n numpy nans or whatever some
rappers um but I did a c profile run as
well and it's all in Step
Dynamics
actually so if we're all in Step
then I assume that the actually the
wrapper is not adding very much overhead
right this Sim is the actual underlying
Sim right
simulators yes you're right okay so how
do we get our how do we get the million
step perf like if we can get the million
steps out of if I can get the million
steps like reasonably soon I can have
this thing training at several hundred
thousand steps per second today
I'll show you what I did on the wrapper
side you'll might uh you might like this
this is with an lstm as
well
environments
U okay so what I did was I took your
environment and I took this controlled
agent mask that you have
here and then the
OBS I select controlled agent mask out
of the OBS so I only get the agents that
are not fundamentally padding you still
end up with padding for dead agents I
can't do anything about that but you
don't end up with
padding um for the you know
non-controlled
what's the current train perf as well
see multiple prams to
tweak
three but
like so Daphne told me that you guys you
profiled the Sim with number it you
profiled the Sim with
masked um with masking taking into
account right more details on slack sure
I have that open on the other side let
me grab
that if you have anything to send there
that's that's good as well
threshold I have 256 worlds which which
ends up being a maximum of like 2,800
agents so I can double
this but
I mean we're like more than an order of
magnitude off
right so I'm assuming that the settings
are like totally messed up
somehow there's also the option of me
trying to get the CPU single thread mode
working I can mess with that as well
potentially
I'll give you a minute to write some
initial thoughts I'm going to go use the
restroom I'll be right
yeah million FPS comes from dense
utilization of Agents if you select
files with more number of valid agents
you'll see big speed UPS Sim skills
number of
Agents with 32 agents you may be able to
fit in more worlds okay so great how do
I select files that have how do I do
that right like that's what I'd like to
do
perfect is there like a strategy I can
is there like a parameter I can use to
like set the number of Agents or
whatever like what what settings did you
guys use when you were benchmarking it
like I can just use that
manual benchmarking two different
scenarios valid
Agents from random selection of
files and considering padding agents to
be
valid
oh if you're considering padding agents
to be valid then this thing is like an
order of magnitude slower at
least there are files with 128 valid
agents I thought they're not very
many I mean from I can see some of these
default files have like two valid
agents I mean I'm assuming that this
thing is linear in the number of actual
like agents or whatever so like is it
possible we can get dense data out of
the CP P Sim itself without wasting time
on all this
saw I don't know if that was in the
paper but DNE showed me the uh the
graphs I I think DNE told me that you
weren't considering padding to be valid
though that like cuz I see that that you
have code that like goes through and
counts the number of valid agent
steps also the fact that you guys were
training at 50,000 steps per second in
the first place means I think I'm
missing something because you'd have to
be
simulating the way s sp3 Works you'd
have to be simulating right
substantially above 50,000 valid agents
per second in order to be getting that
and I'm getting 4200 on a 490
here after doing optimization as
well is there something I have to do
with this episode length parameter so
that it gets applied correctly I don't
see it actually being used in the config
anywhere or anything but I didn't see it
being used anywhere other than for
generating videos in your code either
I'm just looking for
stuff bottleneck CPU or
GPU take your pick it's the simulator it
can run on
either though it looks it looks like
it's the setting of these episode length
is fixed to 91
steps okay so I don't have to deal with
that
cool
um we do we do terminate early as well I
have the early termination if it's
empty unless I messed it
up same as I did with neural MMO
before
um this K unique scenes couldn't figure
out what this was I couldn't increase
this it would give me errors so I don't
know if there's like a way to load
different files or
whatever have you profiled the
Sim I haven't profiled the underlying C
code of the Sim but yeah I've profiled
to make sure I'm not just wasting time
in my
wrappers it's like 90 plus per of the
time is just in the
Sim I already did some settings to
reduce padding
I mean I can I can probably do this to
512 because we only have 2,000 agents
what do we get on on a
CPU with their default
VC I want to see the perf difference
with CPU
20K do I think my CPU VC is so much
better than
do I mean I kind of do think my CPU VC
is good enough that it might be worth
doing
perf am I crazy for thinking I can
probably do
that but you know the thing that's hard
is the
padding my VC is not set up to have
variable numbers of Agents per worker
you can have variable per environment
but not per
worker I don't know if the sampling is
deterministic or
not that's that would be substantially
more work let's start with this for
now so we get
20K 20K CPU 68k
okay well that's actually that's already
a little bit faster than the reported
train
performance if you guys had 50k we're a
bit above 50k now
data density of 30% meaning most of the
agents are dead it's a little bit
you give me the files you're
using I'm using your
defaults like I'm not I don't
have like this is what I have right here
this is your this is just from your uh
your demo code selection K unique n
K
uni if you have a better setting I can
pretty much immediately make this
faster using three files
padded I don't know why I would be doing
that but I guess if that's what it how
it is I mean I would like to have you
know 512 files ideally so you have a
nice mix of data
um all of which would have like some
reasonable number of
scenes how do I get the rest of
them I thought there's like there's a
big data set isn't
there full data set link in the okay so
I have have to download that in order
to
cool mini version with a th000 files
that should be good enough if I can
actually
get like reasonably dense data out of
path to directory cing the containing
the
uh that is
outdated oh
can I is this the right link though
like what where should I put this can I
like just curl this here or no
okay I don't know if I'm downloading
this thing right I don't know how you
use dropbox links Dropbox links from
CLI if I can't curl it we'll
see
curl did I get
that I think dapne said I can probably
like open them like right some script to
like filter through these and try to
load dense
know but it looks like we're going to
have to get the data
set go through the Json going to drop
off see around I'll try to get this
working
yeah we can get like the number of
agents in
SC oh wait it's
this
heck how's it going it's going all right
we got it working on
GPU uh I'm just trying to figure out how
the heck to get this
Dropbox data set with
curl driving me
nuts does GPT know how to do
it this is like might be the one
exception where GPT actually can we'll
why do I think that this is not going to
work something just tells me you
know does it actually
work I guess I'm dumb
okay did something useful for once
broken
clocks broken clock is right twice a
new okay so it's going to
be mini
data
formatted Json
B2 no TL Trane
Speed
um we are going to have to make a little
script here I think
okay import o
list files
here or
open
F data f.
read and I
had hold on let me figure out where I
think I got I have Twitter DMS or
something for how to do
this cuz we need to go find what the
goal here is to go find data files that
aren't all padding
yeah I I do have this in a DM
so you can store the names of files with
greater than n vehicle
occurrences okay how do I read how do I
do this
holy so what is this
one
object
vehicle um
Min
16 Max Vehicles
so what we're doing is we're just going
to filter this
this and this does a
,000
so it's that 240
lines yeah 240
lines
Okay
path should be a
string not
list so it wants a
directory
okay that's actually easier if I think
about it right
where does it think that this
is hold
guessed and actually it actually it has
the path in it doesn't
it it's literally f
name very
nice so I don't need this anymore
right
Min good files
interestingly not any
faster
um I should be able to increase this
though right
and now it takes a long time to open all
the files
data density is higher but the Sim is
just
so slow
have you ever worked in intersection of
computer vision and reinforcement
learning doesn't that mean just like any
environment ever that uses image
observations
we have lots of those everything's
exactly the same as in you know the rest
of RL it's just that it's
slower okay I think that they had Max
objects 128 before right that's what
they
had so let's um
let's
do 128 Max
agents well before we we deal with this
let's let's see how many files they have
that actually have this many
this is a lot of vehicles
right 100 to
[Music]
um how do I know how many files this
is I actually don't know how you do
that one two three
right
uh let me
think how much take time does it take to
combine my knowledge to reinforcement
learning after I become good at computer
vision fundamentals of ML and models
transfer um the thing is that like RL
has a giant additional engineering
component from the simulations and such
that's the main
thing like basically you can go from
when you're good in any field of ml you
can go to any other field of ml in like
2 months but with RL like the thing is
the work tends to just be so much more
engineering
heavy so it's like if you're a good
software engineer or at least if you
write good code and you have a good
knowledge of computer vision you're
probably in a good spot but frankly it's
the engineering component that's harder
in reinforcement
learning at least for the type of stuff
that I'm doing
we will have to recompile their repo uh
where's the
commands there's a flag I need
possible I didn't do anything weird did
I
compiling we'll see whether this
compiles everything
I think they have a lab meeting at the
moment maybe they'll be back in a
bit still few questions for
him okay perfect it should not
match now what we do is we set this to
slower don't
know take care good
well something's wrong right because the
Sim density is too
low so we should just assume I'm
stupid instead of
I don't know how the stupid slack code
block oh wait this is how it works
two separate buttons for code versus
code
somewhere
[Music]
data I don't know what this is
nothing okay
roads a lot of
roads but this is not
is position withd length heading
velocity valid go position
type I don't see it
it so this is what I need in order to be
able to filter
it's not in the file
name TF
record I think I thought that I was told
to look for the number of objects
maybe that's not how it
works
check we'll check the
uh so I was told
greater than n vehicle occurrences okay
actually I'm doing it right according
to DNE I don't know if there's anything
else let me
see there should be something else to
this don't you
think let's let's put a break point like
here
maybe and of
H you
drive back
native yeah okay so this is freaking
wrong because
maybe I'm just being dumb let me
see mini data good
true true false
true yeah this is very
sparse it looks like there are a lot of
vehicles but we don't control very many
of them maybe
mask okay maybe I can just find it in
their
code oops over
so get controlled agents mask is what we
want
get controlled agent mask it's
in controlled State
tensor and then it's control State
tensor we're going to find all the way
through their code however long it
oops
uh
support
tensor controlled
state is what we're looking for
okay well I know what I'm looking for
now
it's controlled
State
this control mode
this it's got to be
here
what is
valid get response type
so max
num controlled
vehicles I didn't mess that up
right oh I don't have Max num controlled
Vehicles
anywhere interesting is there a config
for this
it's 128 by
default it is 128 by default
oh yeah look I have right here Max cun
agents it's going to be the same as the
maxn
that what happened here I had this yeah
here
one agent init type is vehicle which it
is Agent in it. valid
okay well we're going to play with some
other stuff then because this is kind of
weird see do I have any
replies can't read from the files easily
wait you can't read that from files
easily check if the final X and Y is
less than 3 meters from the initial X
and
Y organizing at RLC or I will add would
add it
okay I forgot that that started
right wait Less Than 3
m oh I guess the scale is different
that's fine
ah I need a grumpy puffer emote H for
anytime I have to do stuff like
so now we're just going to say if it's
less than Min
vehicles
or greater than Max
Vehicles continue and then what we're
going to do if
position
zero
goal okay
compute two
distance 3 m
okay agent is valid at the first time
step
problem there is a valid
dict oh for each time
step for each agent
we get far fewer
files one two three let's see 1 two 3
four
five 15 16 19 so we only have 16 scenes
I suppose
oh it has to be more than 0.2 M okay I
did it backwards
1 two 3 four five six 7even 8 9 10 11 12
13 14
16 by 3 is 48
off parked vehicle
I think I'm doing something wrong let
happened I don't know what
happened I need I hit a control c
um record paths let me see how am I
doing this um
num
Vehicles oh I see I just have I have the
logic totally freaking wrong is
this have this logic just totally
freaking
wrong all
right so object start goal L2 if it's
too close not valid you continue
otherwise
Vehicles plus equal to
they said that sounds
correct all
roller coaster
here uh 64 so 64 is going to be the
max we'll do num worlds can do
uh we say maybe
256 and then we'll do 16 unique
scenes 16 unique
scenes and
agents remake the
code remake all the
anything
what oh this is the uh this is fine we
we know what that
is that's
just hold
haha Let's
see we make
progress it's uh
flippy kind of Flippy
what's the uh the
average if I just do this
helps what about the
densities data density so real data
density of
30% and simulation density of only still
20% why is the simulation density only
um 20%
here oh I'm
just where you get brain damage from
doing this too long
[Music]
um this should not be possible it needs
to be higher density than this because
let me make sure I'm Computing this the
way I think I
am sum of mask over numb
worlds or Max numb
I'm gonna make this stupid thing
actually be million steps per second
train come
on you got to be
fast new standard and reinforcement
learning 500k men train come
on at least give me a billion steps an
hour can I get that
right there so much to ask
for yeah ridiculous to ask for by
standards of two months ago but RL moves
fast okay so we actually this is a a
density of about
2/3 which is what we
expect
so okay no this is denser than I I
expected because
be it's not numb agents it's
over these shapes
64% control
density and then the data density
depends heavily on resets and such it's
why it's so
variable let's see how many agents we're
getting
this 10K agents is already big that's
already big we'll have to sweep over
that
uh wrong window
it
so I'm trying to think what we value
more density or
I mean I can get it a little bit higher
by doing a more aggressive cut
off do I really want to do the full data
set right
into let's do 48
plus do we still get enough files if I
do this
not
really we can do five files though right
oh it's so close to being there look at
that
I should really do the full data set I
guess that's like so obnoxious that
that's a lot of
stuff and I'm going to have to like redo
the transcript or the processing script
probably
[Music]
I could also just go down to 32 and use
like a very narrow range in
objects maximum number of objects in the
scene we control
this this is really just max controlled
agents I guess
scene that'll be a good thing to do
right just load their biggest
file
60 well that's not right because we
didn't do
how's the biggest possibly
60 that's
68 so we'll just do
64 64
worlds how's this
do it's
huh stable though
stable
same was this the like way higher for
some
reason I don't think this is actually
higher I actually don't think this is
higher hold on
if I just increase the batch size to
like
64k 65k like
this and do they have update epox one
yeah they
do I think this will give us something
more
stable cuz the estimates are over the
whole batch
is quite
fast why do it Spike up so
high you got to go check their
paper yeah cuz this is definitely slower
right a nice clean
250 let me see where's their
paper where is your
paper they have scaling things on here
right so number of parallel environments
and steps per second
4080 man don't make it easy for me do
you really don't make it easy for for me
over a million
APS 52 worlds average agents per
scenario is
60 okay so spot on with what they
say you know let's test them on that
actually
Let's test
them
do I think I can handle 512 worlds let
me think
60 * 512
30,000 forward
batch it's pretty large
but oh yeah there you go 1.1 million
their claim is correct
just hopped on for a few minutes how's
it going uh I reproduced your a million
steps per second plus by selecting just
one world that has the most number of
agents in the data set which is 60 which
is the average number that was used for
your benchmark as well happens to be and
it's very volatile
but we got 300,000 steps per second
training at the moment so that's six
times faster than your Baseline uh
according to Daphne was
50k this is with 512
worlds and it could be made faster if we
had the full data set I'm
sure it's also very volatile I think we
need to like desync some of the worlds
are you
resetting doesn't include reset times
well that's should include reset times
your I'm just resetting when uh all the
agents are dead
right I actually did manage to get your
FPS over a million with
resets
um the reset should definitely be
included in an asps calculation
so I do get your over a million claim
which is good that reproduces nicely but
I can't reproduce it with like random
files it only reproduces if you actually
have a dense file
higher but I'm not resetting all the
Sims right I'm only resetting individual
Sims when they're
done see I passed the index of the done
world
or is this only going to occur at the
end of the episode I would assume that
this would occur when
um yeah it occurs when all the
terminals I'd assume that's when like
all the agents have crashed or the world
is done right
reset doesn't happen until you call step
the next
time but it only resets the individual
n that I'm calling reset on right it's
not resetting all of the M or anything
right world yeah that's
fine that shouldn't screw with my timing
my timing just runs through this whole
thing with random actions for 20
seconds 400,000 SPS at the end I think
it's 300K average
train 1 mil
Sim very
volatile
um probably configure out how to train
this oh while you're here do you know
how to make this thing not Segal When I
close it because I can't run sweeps
because the thing doesn't close cleanly
if this would close cleanly I could run
this through
carbs at
300K that's a billion steps per hour so
I can I can train a billion steps per
hour per GPU with the
SIM individual worlds being heavier to
reset I have one world I have one one
world that is 60 agents I took the
biggest file I could
find 60 valid agents
so apparently they're not all actually
valid in your sim uh based on these it
says 87.5 R 87.5% of them are so I was
expecting 60 agents and I'm only getting
like 55 is or something like that
um data density is actually ooh dat
density is
zero that's
sketchy I will have to look at
that Sim density okay something is wrong
then CU these should not be
mask H well I'll figure that out and see
if we're actually getting the SPs I
think we're
getting I would like to know how to make
this not crash I think I could figure
the rest
out I made a i defined a close function
and just called M close that doesn't
seem to do it still seg
subprocess that's funny you were using
subprocess because this m breaks in
subprocesses by default unless you use
spawn instead of fork as the default
method
um I don't know how you got it to work
there I don't think that there's a way
if the thing hard segals I don't think
think that there's a way I can run
sweeps on it like it needs to be able to
exit
um
yeah I'm not going to be able to do that
for this though
because
um like I need to hook this into wand
B right w b manages the subprocess for
the experiments
so I need this I need to figure out how
to have this m exit cleanly if we want
to have sweeps on
this I mean I would think that that
would also just be a good thing in
general for the environment because this
thing like it'll crash your shell
constantly it segals basically every
time you exit like it'll screw up
debugger sometimes there's a little bit
of uh there's definitely some stuff
going on
oh all the worlds are finished at the
same
interesting so that's why the data
density is like
this so I'll have to I'll have to
calculate this differently then to get
the real data
density okay that's my bad
Cuda context needs to be owned by one
process needs to be passed to any spawn
processes I'm not even running this in a
sub process
now but yeah unfortunately like the main
thing I wanted to do with puffer with
this right I can give you like the super
fast training config so that's like a
right now I have like a six-fold train
Improvement we using decent configs with
puffer
um probably you can find if you go
through the whole data set right with
this script you can find enough
environments that are dense to you get
even a little higher than this
um I'll see if I can manually find some
hyper parameters maybe that are like
okay but yeah like carbs automated on
this would just be and you'd be able to
100 experiment sweeps on this
in yeah 100 X10 mil would be an hour
billion steps an hour 100 X10 mils an
hour 10 hours for 100x 100 Mil 10
billion steps of experiments
how can I reproduce the seg fault does
it not seg fault for you just like
whenever the program
exits like whenever you do anything with
it it doesn't just like Segal
Vault not really no okay well in that
case what I'll do is I'll finish this up
I'll try to get all the container stuff
pushed together I'll figure out how I
can automate that so that we have like
the config or whatever on puffer and
then you can use the container
okay I wonder if this m. close has
anything to do with it like if you're
just not allowed to close the
en that would be really weird though
close doesn't do anything except C
delete I got like internal internal Cuda
Heap allocation errors last night when I
tried to run the
sweeps look at that 15 seconds for a 5
mil parameter run sigf fall
there you go so that's seg fault when I
queue up all the jobs right for a sweep
we'll just kill the The Sweep
Runner which is the Annoying Thing
memory why this is the end of the run
it's when the program terminates that it
seg
fals okay that is possible for the Cuda
Heap errors yes but it's still seg
faults
I'll try to see if the sweep runs even
with the seg volts I doubt it though
doesn't seg
fault yeah no worries I'll give you um
I'll finish this up I'll try to get you
the container
today and uh then you'll be able to play
with it I'll get you like a container
that runs this thing nice and really
fast for
zero well that's not
right okay and we'll put a break point
here
done oh because I'm dumb and I left a
break point
oops we focus on YouTube all of this
stuff is uh free it's open
source all the stuff from today will be
committed up by tonight it's all in
GitHub AI uh GitHub puffer right here
and if you want to support the project
just give it a star helps me out a ton
key what was I doing with Sim density
versus data density
density think control density is what we
need
right no wait I was
write yeah because it's always going to
be 100 that's
fine and we don't need this is
[Music]
density we could substantially improve
this
well I mean we have it running now at
least so
python we still if it's still out of
memory
I can try that to see if that works
usually a lot of the killed ones don't
actually work okay so this does actually
break
unfortunately I think we're going to
have to bring back
offload um
I don't know why it's this much
[Music]
now this divisible yeah okay 16 this is
kind of reason reble it's just
like too many environments for this
train let's fix some variables so that
we can get um good metrics
metrax the goal for today is to have a
sweet demo in which we just like
essentially obliterate this Benchmark
through ludicrous
scale because we can train it nearly 10
times the speed of the original
project and uh then we hand the lab
there you know their nice new shiny
version and they're happy because they
get a new shiny version that's just like
stupid fast and I'm happy because puffer
did a
thing and then we get one tril ion
puffer stars that sounds
[Music]
down I think it's because they just
don't do anything though because the
goals go down
these are things that could be valid
ranges
happening basically they're not
achieving
goals this one is
weird I'll have to ask him about that
let's see update Epoch
one
Lambda
five put this
cuz I think they're just learning to not
do anything
I'm going to use a restroom I'll be
right back and uh we will
okay
um yeah I'm very suspicious of the data
if this is not solving stuff it'd be
really nice to be able to run the w b
sweep
but first of all let's go let's be smart
Let's
here uh we'll track this and it's not
going to be easy to get this down onto
my main machine though I really should
render it
though well okay we'll we'll try a
little bit not smart
first just to
see should be substantially easier if I
can get this to work and then do the
container
h.x there's no way this works right
inside of a
container I mean I'll bite but there's
like no way this works link
key I know it's X foring but I just
don't think it'll work inside the
container without me having to do some
stuff
linky do you actually have forwarding
working with the puffer boxes that would
be a very nice thing to have we don't
currently have that working as far as
I'm
us trying to think like what are the
obvious gas here
well that's suspicious that the rewards
are that high on the first St
I'm trying to think about the
possibilities
let me try a more reasonable setting
just initially just to
oh wait
maybe it was just hyper parameters
well this also I'd imagine is a hard
Scene It has 60 agents on it
definitely something happens
here so I mean that means that it's got
to be learn able to learn something so
we really need the automated sweeps
now
um what I'm taking from
this The Sweep should just discover
everything but now the seg fault on exit
is rough yeah look at this it's gonna
this will be good
prams I don't know if that would be any
better
even though this is our slowest run this
is still faster than their uh their
training
setup for
I want to bet that this is just going to
be hyper parameters and I'll be wasting
my time if I spend more time when I
can't uh tune it
automatically I think it's pretty darn
likely pretty darn
likely okay so what we're going to do
then
is we'll add it as a hyper parameter
yeah we'll add it as a hyper parameter
but we got to still figure out the seg
folting thing
maybe in the torch am we can
see it should be a
close probably not here okay is it in
the
close is
it maybe it's self. sim.
we'll go look for
it how's this
doing I think I sto this for
now this is like reasonable enough
stuff there's learned something the mean
reward per episode is weird
though well let's not let's not do
we don't need
track see if we can find the close
this we'll have to we'll have to just
try stuff
try think what else we could do to find
where to close this
close yeah so it's not explicitly
defined they like they have it in these
rappers but they don't Define it in the
en
yeah seg fault still
vaults or if it can continue as long as
I don't add of memory the
node
[Music]
uh yeah well that didn't go well
right set C to Heap
you can sweep it with a seg bolt and it
should
continue but not might not release R
yeah well this isn't working
there's like no way around this either
unfortunately
because
the best I could do would be a Jank like
random hyper parameter sweep without the
nice
graphs let's at least get the end of
binding done for this in the next like
30 minutes and then
actually I'm going to take myself uh
here's what I'm going to do I'm going to
take a quick break I'm going to go make
myself a shake I'll be back in a few
minutes and then I will make it so that
we can configure environment parameters
as part of a sweep I'll launch like a
really basic janky random search because
that's all I'm going to be able to do
from here um and then I'll clean up all
of this stuff and I'll push it and then
it'll be on them to get this thing to
not Segal that's a pretty reasonable
request I would say environment should
not Segal on
termination um and if they are able to
do that then we'll be able to do we'll
be able to do more
all
right I might have gotten ridiculously
distracted but I'm
back I don't know train of thought is
just not there
lately I need some more sleep probably
let me check a couple
things
yeah
so let's start by fixing the environment
file well not that hard come
on um
this is
Jen Maxum objects is wrong it's supposed
to be Max cont
bad
suggestions then we'll
that
it it looks good to
and then what we get to
do weep.
parameters sweep. parameters. m.
parameters
do um
max no we're not going to sweep the max
cont agents that's ridiculous we're
going to do no
worlds
we're going to do
worlds we're going to do uniform uniform distribution or log
uniform uniform distribution or log
distribution we'll do uniform
distribution and the Min will
be
16 Max will be 512
20 million total time steps site metric
will be goal
achieved batch sizes
are
things it's not really a puun visit
just do
mode train back
native
and drive
rack
this and I can't even do this it has to
be mode sweep which is disgusting
which I don't even know if works because
we do carb sweep so often so we'll do
sweep carbs we'll just pick a random
data
okay so we have a really Jank sweep
going it's not going to get any of the
nice WB features um
because it's just if the M didn't Segal
we'd be fine I don't know why this n
freaking
segals I just want to make sure it
actually does this and then if this
works I'll start packaging all this up
and then you guys can get to play with
it as you can see we have comfortably at
least a train of you know well over 200k
here um it can go higher can go lower
depends I've seen over 300K I've seen
even over 400k though I don't know how
real that
is the base starting was 50k from s
sp3 puffer Li plus optimizations
this has a a simpler main network but it
has an lstm whereas there's does not
have the original net does not have an
lstm let's see what happens when this
run
finishes I don't actually know what will
happen
steps it takes a little longer um than
it says than it suggests with the time
because there's this extra there's a
like 10% extra at the end that does uh a
high quality
evaluation okay it's synced
fails okay that looks good it's
disgusting and Jank and whatever but it
works
[Music]
okay
and forgot to set up caching it's okay
we'll fix that
we also need to
do some stuff with the mini data right
48 to
64 we'll
do biggest
file this will be
filtered
data filtered
data
so I think this will now work to
generate to regenerate our data set for
us
okay get filtered
data we're good
file so we're just going to commit like
the small sample of data
set so I can push to my
Branch commit some
stuff are you
pring uh I don't know if they'll want
this as a PR they can have it if they
want
it I have including it on the uh the
puffer tank
though we have our filtered version of
the data set that runs very fast or that
lets you train very fast we have like
the biggest file that we're training on
we have uh a really janky hyper
parameter sweep running but we got
something I'd say we've done pretty well
for you know two three days work on this
um we will still have to mess with a few
things though to make all this [ __ ]
work we not too
whoops it's just
en en name true
right so
en LD Library
path right
cach so we set these n
variables we clone
it puffer tank GPU
Drive
CD build
well this actually looks like it
[Applause]
built we'll see how this goes
we're going to update these
builds probably we'll have to add the
Sim
link I don't know if we remember to do
that what else we got in the
meantime we got GPU
drive so um this is what we're going to
do did you ever fix the madona CPU issue
they sent me a thing on
it I got the GPU one running reasonably
fast
um the heck which of these are why are
these running for 60 million
steps now these are two
new it's got to
be I don't set these to run for 50
million steps did I
oh I moved the data
directories
file biggest
file why have a big file when you have
the biggest file
mini data SL biggest
file this looks good to
work y it works
[Music]
okay so this is now
pushed this one is also so we're going
to have to
um let's make sure that we didn't miss
anything cuz this is going to make us
rebuild the
so this is uh why we were had to be
careful with this because now we have
this
achieved and we're going to hope this
this one works out of the box and if so
we will send this on over to the lab and
say here is your you know out of the box
working
experience and then uh it's only 400
p.m. so I'll think of a couple other
things to do maybe or maybe I won't
we'll
see could always just go grab an early
dinner and go to sleep at 7 that'd be
nice
be nice if they had a ppie package for
uh the project but I know that's pretty
hard to set
up pip install GPU drive would be a
really nice addition but we'll do the
second best thing which is puffer tank
GPU Drive
this little bit of boring
stuff with all of this but uh I think we
made made out relatively
well we
got decently dense
data we don't have ragged tensor support
but everything else is good
technically we have a little
optimization we could
do Least Complicated way to do X pass
through has been run SSH server from
within
Docker instead of
the post
machine big rips were had here yeah
that's
rough that's okay I didn't expect you to
have something
easy I do that type of thing all the
time where it's like I just spend a
couple hours see if it's doable and then
it ends up not being like not being
reasonable to do right
push we should have something real cool
to post from all
this does s brass work does anybody
know like does their stuff work for
training
I've seen them posted a few models of
their own
okay and
then
don't see if it
works likely we'll have to rebuild
depths a couple times so we'll have to
rebuild two
stages to fix a few
things but you know we're like
hopefully an hour or less from Shipping
this should have given me an error
message shouldn't
wrong okay so the variables did get
set this is updated
cpython make-
J it did not
get
renamed oh you see
this freaking comment
does that do
it probably that breaks it
right assume
at how many more pedop flops do I have
to throw at this before it's at the
Elite 4
no
fuchsia I thought we were already way
past
there shouldn't we be gym
8 with script are we at gym 8 with
scripts at
least do we have eight badges
[Music]
anywhere oh we are okay that's freaking
awesome do you know how far how far
through
that managed to beat the Elite 4 but
never in a full
run uh okay that's freaking
awesome yeah okay that's very very close
then build to create symbolic link
that's right okay
file wait path to
file path to link
dot
path
to oh cuz poer Li isn't cloned
okay that's fine though
so path to file
is hoer tank
SL
drive
five every major event actess a
filter yeah yeah there's got to be some
sort of like thing to prevent the data
from being bad because like agents are
stuck it's kind of a unique environment
in that sense nobody's ever done like an
M that that that is that
long I mean if we wanted to do this as
like a research environment right the
way that we would do it like that we
would represent this is would just be
like with a stupidly long maze right we
just make like a really stupidly long
maze
um and then we'd see like you know well
okay agents get stuck what do we do yada
yada
right day three is not terrible as well
for this project day three out of the
box GPU drive
support with like 4 to 6X faster
training than the
original it's pretty good
longer term explor it's not exactly
exploration it's not exactly the same
thing CU you're actually you're doing it
it's just that agents like some portion
of the agents are getting stuck like you
could fix that immediately with state
resets right just reset every so often
just reset to the agent with the most
event Flags right like capture state of
that agent set all the agents to that
and go from
gu has swarming logic that swarms to the
highest
five I
mean I would suggest
doing just like reset to the top and
yeah and then don't use the scripts and
see how far you can get if you want to
do it without that's kind of go
explor it's very restrictive cuz you
need a simulator that can do that
but like honestly if that's what it
takes like we can always just tell
people hey we got to make Sims that have
fast state resets right like if this
ends up just being an engineering
problem I know how to build Sims that
can do
that it's not that
hard you basically just do what Pokemon
does right where like the whole state is
one big chunk of contiguous memory and
then resetting state is just a mem copy
it would be slightly annoying but I
could build that sort an engine for
want to see how it performs no scripts
I'll speed up my
progress lack of events in
fuchsia and I get them to stay there y
gotta say it's really nice to be able to
just give people Dockers and never have
any setup
issues four days of training to get to
that point by it INF fuchsia they'll
stay there playing the percent
game so again right
if yeah if you just reset to the the
highest event flag position
right then they'll stay
there and you said that starting from
fuchsia you can get through the whole
game seems like that would work though I
don't know what's wrong with that guy's
thing if he's already doing that why
hasn't he beaten
it also when did he say that he could
solve it in a month I want to know the
time frame on that because usually the
uh the thing with Engineers right is
that you uh you multiply by two and then
you go up to the next place value so
like if he says 1 month it would be 2
years
okay bugs and
segals that's
puffer tank should have the stable
Branch not the dev Branch by default
right
yeah definitely should have the stable
not the dev I don't need to maintain two
containers either just for people to
switch branches
[Music]
look at that
let's see if this is really any
faster if it's not substantially faster
I'll leave it on 64
default claim 200k and be good
250 okay I think I just leave it on this
and claim
okay this will rebuild I will be able to
push this I'll be able to be done
early get myself an early dinner and go
to sleep at like 7 or something
ridiculous and get good
sleep I'm
I keep finding stuff to
fix for
gets rid of one
warning or one like annoyance for users
[Music]
every minor annoyance you
remove as a huge
working
okay last
rebuild I hope it's the last
the real question is what do I go get
for dinner
once well not quite a little over
not much
though so yeah for folks here the plan
is we're going to ship this you all will
be free to try it if you want it'll be
super easy to play with all the crazy
cursed things have been fixed out of the
box you can play with it at 5x the
original
speed quarter million steps per second
train million plus
simulation there will be hyper parameter
sweeps as well I will launch one of
those be a really Jank hyper parameter
sweep though
because unfortunately we do not have the
technology um this m has to not seg
faal it does seg faal at the end of
training which is fine for single runs
not nice for sweeps I have a hacky
workaround script but doesn't let us do
carbs and I'm not going to make I'm not
going to go through the whole day of
effort to like make carbs work with a SE
folting M when the m just should not be
seg
folting if like they if they really ask
me to and they like really there's no
other way around it then maybe I will
but
like the M should not seg it's just
Jank hopefully this makes more people
use the m and Puffer
and
puffer I have to upload the image don't
I before
perfect Star Puffer yep if you're
watching and haven't starred puffer live
please go ahead and do helps me out a
whole
ton currently working for free
and stars on puffer will make it easier
for me to not have to work for free all
all of this stuff will still be freely
available it will let me generate rev
for puffer as
well stuff like that actually
car let's make like a dumb meme to go
with this for tomorrow for uh for right
now
uh let's see if it just makes
something it make something
image okay we also need to go get our
Puffer fish our favorite uh our
friend where's the
or esteemed members that's
funny that's
cool thanks
aian what do we think this will do we
think this will do
they're looking at the seg fault now
which is
awesome going to have to get
whoop
there we
go
B There is our hyper parameter
sweep
we'll see uh I've got a WP here uh
looking at one of the authors looking at
this
tank uh let me go find some food to
order on the side here we going to end
stream pretty soon anybody has any cool
RL questions I'll answer some stuff but
other than
that I should have kept the ding board
logo my
you know the really weird thing to me
about California is just the lack of
diners missed me a good
diner
well link key Diner would be actually be
a good way to get to know her there you
go your joke backfires for
once wait was that your joke or link
Key's that he would constantly make no
not link key what's the N other guy n
not Nishi right Nishi yeah
damn it my head is like I'm just
fried my food get
we'll order this and if I don't have any
replies we'll just call
bad all right well I think we're uh
we're set for today not the most
interesting stream I know kind of just
some chill Dev um
nothing crazy but sometimes you know
getting stuff working like this you end
up just doing a lot of like slow Dev
stuff which is why I try not to have to
do too much of it I find it very boring
but
um the result is
good for like three days of
work three like not crazy crazy long
days of work we got this all
working um it's fast need some hyper
pram
sweeps they're looking at the seg
faulting behavior for us for
that we actually we can double check the
last thing we'll do
today is I'll uh I'll show the hyper
Prem sweep it's kind of
Jank but if we just go to projects
carbs right
here go like
this right you can just turn all these
on and then you can see oh look you know
we have different runs here and some of
them will do better some of them will do
worse and it'll run like a hundred of
these and maybe it'll find something who
knows
anyways uh I think that's it
so yeah I will I'm going to call it an
early day I get some food going to get
some rest and then I will be back
tomorrow and probably Saturday maybe
with more on this depending on if
there's anything new to do if not we'll
be back to Atari mooba uh other hyper
pram stuff and generally like getting
ready for this big simulation update
night everybody